Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome to Contemp
Now, this is the first game that I've been able to record
Since I got back to L.A
And I'm eager to start on an indie horror game
Just because I want to get the crap scared out of me
And I hope this is gonna deliver
Now this is made by a college student
I believe anyway...
Oh... Hello?
Hi!
Oh, boy
So why did I drive out here?
And I'm assuming that's my car, and not just two lamps in the darkness
Oh, boy.
Hi!
Is this my Grandma's house?
Grandma!
It's me! I'm home!
Oh, did you miss me?
(wind chimes)
I love the chimes that you have here, they always remind me of home
Oh!
Grandma, you scamp!
(laughing a little) You unlock this door right now and let me in!
I promise I'm not scary, oh, hi
Well, ok, I guess I'll just go into the tool shed
Grab an axe
Hack my way into my own Grandma's house!
Oh, Hi
It's quiet in this shed
I don't know why, but it's quiet
Alright, can I run? No.
This is the standard crawl that I'm gonna have around my Grandma's house
She told me strictly NEVER to run
Running is ba-ohh
Hi
Hello
(rumbling)
Ooh, rumbley!
Why is it so rumbley in here?
Also, who's that?
(Creaky floorboards)
It sounds like there's a storm or a train passing by, but-
GRANDMA! I TOLD YOU TO FIX THESE FLOORS!
Grandma?
Something tells me Grandma needs to get a maid because this place looks awful
Ugh... GRANDMA!
Where's all those cookies you promised me?
Where's all the lovely goo- (something breaks) -oodies?
Ok
GRANDMA!
It's too early to play a game of hide-and-seek so why won't you just come on out and let me..
Enjoy what I came here to enjoy, a nice relaxing weekend
With family, oh.
Ah!
Ooh!
I don't need to take a bath right now
Oh hi
Wha, Grandma!?
This place don't look so good!
There's bugs and trash in the shower
I don't know why, but okay.
I'll go upstairs?
(Eerie door creak)
(Deep woosh)
Hi...
(smaller woosh)
Hi........
Hi...
Oh! Hiiii!
Oh! Hiiiiiii!
Uh...
Hi?
(Click)
HAI!
FFFuck you.
I did not just get scared by coats, I was doing my vocal exercises of screaming at random points in my life
It's what my vocal coach told me!
Da-
That's the best thing I can do for my-  (suddenly quiet) voooiice...
Oh (chuckle) Oh no!
Why did you scratch out Grandpa's head?
Did you scratch out Grandpa's head?
Ok, its just the other door
Alright!
Well this is open now!
Which is nice I guess...
Clickity Click Clack
Oh
Lemme stare into this, I'm sure this is gonna be good
Ooh boy, Oh! Movies!
My Favorite!
(movie seems to start up normally, but sound cuts out)
(in a news broadcast) [Woman #1: ...parts of your body broken.
Woman #2: Karen...]
[Karen: Now I've never tried it myself. You may be surprised to hear that.
(both laugh)]
[Karen: But I'm told it's not easy to spin around on your head.]
[And health professionals say it may not be safe, either.]
[They've seen some injuries-] (sound cuts out)
Okay
Is there a point to that or was that just..
Oh, Hi. Jeez, i thought that was a face up there
Also, I like these, I like these, uh...
Parody videos here.
Absurd objects
You mean "Stranger Things"?
HoboCop?
Rec It Rolph?
I wanna watch Rec It Rolph.
Alright, Grandma, I'm going upstairs
(phone rings)
Don't worry, I'll get it!
I'll get it, Grandma! Don't get up! Don't get up!
Woah (phone stops ringing)
(Warbley blackout)
HAIAHH!
HAHA!
Got Ya!
I think...
Grandma?
(man on recorder)[ ...making deep inside it. No longer I can hide. And it's telling me once more it's time to run.]
[But I cannot tell when I'll be coming home.]
(tape recorder garbles, high-speed unintelligible sounds)
(sound stops)
(High Pitched Garbles) Okay, Alright then.
(man on recorder comes back)
Thank you for that
[Man: See, there's no...]
Oh! You're not done! O-o-okay, keep going!
[Man: ...light on the horizon showing where I long to be.]
[I travel on.]
(click)
I don't know why I'm standing like this, but I am very motion sick.
Alright, lets carry on
Hi, Okay.
Grandma, you okay?
Grandma! Did you fall?!
I'll help you!
Hit your life alert!
You've Fallen!
oh, boy
And you can't get up?
Oh, It's a big coicle
Okay
(softly) Grandma? Grandma?
Oh
Grandma?
How do I open that?
Oh
Ugh
I found the coat room I think
Oh, ugh, wait, I didn't close that!
HI!
OOOOKAY!
GRANDMA WILL NEVER FIND ME IN HERE!
(metal creaking)
(door shuts)
Was that the attic opening?!
(knocking)
NO THANK YOU! I DON'T WANT ANY!
Nonononono!
Uh-uh, I am, I am too smart to go near that door!
Here I go near that door. Click!
Okay, Hi-diddily-ho Neighbor!
Up a-diddily-doodily I go!
Oh!
Grandma! I love the deathly green mist you've done with the place!
That's not a good sound
(random nonsense gibberish)
HEY!
HI! OKAY! HI! NO, DON'T GET UP!
(tense, loud music)
HEY, NO! I DON'T WANT ANY!
(one breath sound, then silence)
(noise gets rapidly louder)
(silence, save for wind chimes)
OH!
Oh! I'm Outside!
My flashlight doesn't work!
It's like I never was!
It's l- wha- I always have a good time at Grandma's house!
Oh! Boy! I bet I get to go home pretty- n- I jus- please! HOOOO!
Okay!
Alright then!
Okey-dokey!
Okely-dokely!
Kahahaha!
Ke! He! He! He! He!
I guess.
Ooooookay
Well
That was Contemp
And that was actually awesome
That was legitimately awesome
I had a great time with that
It was soo spooky!
Grandma's House is scarier than I remember!
Anyway
So that was Contemp
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Lemme know your thoughts down in the comment section below
And whoever made this, I don't exactly know the name, but there were no credits, but whoever made this, great job
You did an amazing job, the ambiance, with the experience, with the creepiness of it, really, Really good stuff here
So thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you, in the next video, bu-bye!
(horror outro music)